Septin elmo was a writer who created black propaganda on behalf of the British
government since used fake news to fight the Nazi regime through postcards,
court documents,
and pirate radio programs.
Delmah and the rest of the secret service infiltrated the minds of the German
people using elements of violence,
sex,
and death.
In their stories.
Do you suddenly break down the morale of the Nazis?
So who was Sefton Delmar?
Why was he most likely the only man on earth who could have become the true
master of black propaganda?
Dennis Sefton.
Domo was born in 1904 in Berlin,
Germany as a child.
Everyone called him Tom,
but as an adult,
everyone remembered him by his parents can joins last names and he was a known
as Sefton Dell Map.
It's father Frederick Sefton.
Delmah taught English ads,
Berlin University.
His parents were both from Australia and they had Jewish heritage.
They registered his birth at the British consulate so that he could be a dual
citizen.
He only spoke German before the age of five,
which his parents chose to do on purpose,
hoping he would blend in better.
He grew up to become bilingual in both English and German,
but his parents still raised him to understand his Australian ancestry at home.
At the start of World War One,
his father Frederick was removed from his position as a professor at the
university because he was the so called enemy aliens and he was forced to live
in the room of Ben Internment camp growing up in Germany.
The other children in school labeled him as an enemy and he was isolated from
his peers and bullied for being different even though they were exactly the
same.
In 1917 Frederick was released from the camp through a prisoner exchange program
between the British and the Germans,
but instead of going back to Australia,
the whole family was deported to England,
so soft and done.
What was able to transfer to a school in London since German was his first
language,
he couldn't help but speak with accents as far as English classmates working
son,
though he was considered the enemy once again and he was also isolated from the
other children in the school.
Even though this must have been difficult,
this life of being stuck in between two worlds,
this is precisely why he was able to understand both cultures so completely
since he was ostracized for the sound of his voice or the words that he used.
It only made him pay more attention to those details and this would all come
rather in handy later on in his adult life.
World War One ended in 1918 when Sefton Delmer was 14 years old.
Despite the fact that he had endured so much bullying in his younger years,
he still embraced the fact that he was bilingual.
He runs on to study at Oxford University where he studied German possibly to
follow in his father's footsteps of securing a job as a professor.
However,
the never did start a teacher in Korea.
He instead chose to fully embrace the other passion in his life and that was
writing and this,
this was just the beginning of his destiny.
Okay.
After graduating Oxford University,
Sefton Delmar got a job for a magazine called the Daily Express.
Since he was bilingual,
he became very valuables in the magazine and translating the news coming out of
Germany in order to make the British public are web.
He was able to become friendly with the Nazi officer Ernst Rom,
who introduced him to add off Hitler in 1932 at this time,
Hitler had just lost his first election and he wouldn't become the chancellor of
Germany until 1933 Sefton download was able to travel with it and are on his
private plane and listened to all of his plans for what he wanted for Germany.
He became the first British journalists do ever secure an interview without off
Hitler and he traveled to Berlin to report the day when he took office in 1933
this may seem like a monumental event that should have set him off right then
and there,
but at the time no one would have predicted that Hitler would become this evil
dictator.
He was promising to bring Germany out of the financial hardships that did an
injured after World War One and he was even given the title of Man of the year
in Time magazine.
So as far as the daily express was concerns,
there were far more important things going on elsewhere,
but that same year,
the daily express sent him to France to work out of their offices in Paris.
At that time,
Paris was the place to be for some of the most creative people in history.
Some of the most famous writers of that time were living as working there in the
late 1920s to the early 1930s and many of them were actually friends with one
another as well.
These writers,
they were the so called lost generation and they indulged heavily in drugs,
sacks and jazz.
While in Paris,
Sefton Delmah met and fell in love with a woman named Isabel Nicholas.
She was a very successful artist,
designer and model.
She was quite beautiful.
Then she became the muse for several famous painters and sculptors,
including Public Picasso and a lot of ways they were a perfect match for one
another and in 1935 the two were married.
A couple of years later,
Sefton Delmar became a correspondent during the Spanish civil war,
which lasted from 1936 to 1939 General Francisco Franco was trying to take over
the Spanish government's is on behalf of fascism and both Nazi Germany and Italy
were sending money and ammunition to Franco's Almay.
Stepsons downward became good friends with Hemingway,
who was that?
Writing the scripts and doing the voiceover for a documentary called the Spanish
earth and other items.
Martha Gellhorn was also there for Colliers magazine.
She was one of the only female war correspondence.
She was also willing to put our life in danger to get the scoop on a story.
She would data,
actually Mary Hemingway making her his third wife,
a large group of these writers,
photographers and filmmakers.
They live together in the hotel Florida,
in Madrid,
and they were often singing and drinking in the hotel lobby and Barb,
they all believed that by covering the events of the Spanish civil war,
they could shed light on the fact that out of Hitler was already pushing his
fascist regime on the rest of the world and that the Nazis were an indeed very
dangerous,
but these writers would have no idea that soon enough their own countries would
be at war as well.
Then there was nothing that they could do to stop it
all the brink of world war two secret agents and spies were commonplace
throughout Europe.
Her Majesty's secret service was paying close attention to anyone that they
believed could be a Nazi sympathizer,
including Sefton Delmar.
It was like he was living through his elementary school experience all over
again because the Germans believed that he was an agent for mic x and they no
longer allowed him to interview at off Hitler or any other high ranking members
of the Nazi party.
It was only after he returned to London and started working for the German
branch of the BBC that the British government knew that they could actually
trust him.
Sefton Delmar wants described one of adult Hitler speeches is coming from his
lying stinking teeth.
While that's not exactly the most professional thing a journalist could say on
the air,
it actually did work out very well for him because in 1940 he was recruited by
the political warfare executive branch or the p w e for short and that's sign.
The British secret service was very concerned about a private radio program
called workers challenge,
which was broadcasting from inside of the UK,
but it was actually a German propaganda show run by talented actors who spoke
fluent English.
They were posing as an antiwar program and they spread fake news to bring down
the morale of the British troops,
the British government ostomate and make his own version of a radio show.
That was black propaganda.
The goal was to give out roughly 80% real facts,
but try to slip in 20% fake news that was meant to subvert the Germans.
He wholeheartedly agreed to do the job that his wife,
Isabelle,
was excited to help in whatever way she could.
In 1941 the government gave him a requisitions country house in Bedford show
where he worked together with a team on creating propaganda.
Isabel illustrated fake post scans of German soldiers with French prostitutes.
This was meant to make French men Bengie and jealous and inherently dislike the
Nazis.
At that time.
Isabel's illustrations,
they were sexy and suggestive,
but they were not exactly pornographic.
I mean this was the early 20th century is definitely started a radio broadcast
and so he wrote scripts under the alias of De Chef,
he heart of German immigrants and accent named Paul Saunders to be the voice of
the character.
He spoke with a perfect Berlin accidents and they had a strong enough radio
tower to make it seem as if the show was being broadcast from Germany.
Does chef claims it to be a loyal Nazi and he was simply giving insider
information to inform his fellow comrades.
They used course language and spoke out against the enemies of the Third Reich.
Since Delmar grew up in Germany,
he knew how to write these words as if they were truly coming from a German
person and no one would ever know that the show was actually produced by the
English sessions.
Elma had a great sense of humanity.
He knew how to capture an audience's attention.
Much of the fake news that he wrote included sexual stories,
which was enough to keep the audience listening on a regular basis.
For example,
he wants to write that the British were trying to get gem and prisoners of war
to give up their secrets by tying them up and torturing them with strippers to
chef urged them to be strong and it's not to give into temptation.
Cylinders would have to tell these stories as if he were outraged at the English
saying,
don't give in to these perversions.
Say Nothing.
Then once you had their attention,
he would go on to tell fake news that was secretly meant to demoralize the
enemy.
Sefton Zalman was also a pause of the governments undergrounds propaganda
committee.
It was their job to connect rumors there were already spreading in German
communities and use those as the basis of the fake news.
By me using this strategy,
they were simply confirming what people were already whispering about,
so it was far easier for the audience to believe that what was being said was
true.
Along with that show,
Sefton Zelma wrote and produced a second radio program called Atlantic Center,
which was meant to seduce German soldiers.
They played jazz music,
which had been forbidden to German citizens.
A female actress called agonists Bernal,
who they call to Vicky it read the scripts and has sultry voice together with
another writer and spy,
Ian Fleming.
The Elmo put together stories that were basically erotic fan fiction of various
fantasy scenarios between German men and English women.
These stories worked exactly as he had hoped.
A former German officer named Horts Brito says that he would listen to Atlantic
center with the rest of the men who was stationed in a u boat.
Once he saw how truly beautiful the actress wells,
he asked for a copy of her photo and jokes.
If there were TVs on board the u boat and we saw these pictures,
a lot of them would say,
the Orris finished.
Let's go home and be with English girls.
Of course,
not everyone was a fan of these sexy stories.
A politician named staff had crips got a hold of an English translation of the
Dutch chef broadcast.
The particular script he read was a dirty story and that was an origins.
Crips was disgusted by how crude they were.
Heroes,
if this is how we win the war,
I'd rather lose it.
Despite receiving this criticism,
that show was able to continue.
The black propaganda team has really figured out what made men tick.
Ins there subversive messages manipulating them through sexual desires and
fantasies was actually working very well.
He has laser.
Ralph to the wall was one Delmas co-writer.
Ian Fleming has a light bulb moments if the German soldiers would go crazy
fantasizing over these characters,
so with the rest of the men in the worlds,
he continued to write these sexy stories.
I need this time.
The main character was a British spy who's adventures were based on his own
experiences during the war heroes,
pulp fiction novels about his alter ego.
James Bond's Dan was wife Isabelle would laser say that they were both having
the time of their lives creating this propaganda.
She thought it was hilarious that the government was essentially paying her to
draw a pornography for a living.
They recruited some of the most talented artists in the country to come and join
the team and in del Mar had his own sense of humor for initiating new recruits.
A 22 year old artist named Marian why on was asked to join the secret
organization.
There were several British generals that are on the death,
our briefing.
They were all wearing their uniforms without even a hint of a smile on their
faces that Alma said that if she told anyone about the secret mission they were
about to give her,
she would be sent to jail and stuff.
At 10 years of hard labor.
She nervously agreed and as he slid a postcard of adult Hitler across the table,
the postcard was titled with the German phrase or two we have,
we hold.
Our first assignment was due tamper the guard,
so it looked as if Hitler was holding his own penis in his hand.
Decades later,
Marian White,
I'm told this story during an interview for a documentary.
She said that looking back,
she could have laughed,
but the atmosphere of the room was so serious.
Story simply agreed to do the duty for our country as she left the room to get
started.
[inaudible] called out,
but not too big.
Marian.
Meanwhile,
in Germany,
the Nazis Minister of propaganda,
Joseph Goebbels has an entirely different strategy.
Instead of using Sutherland's creative writing,
he was loud and confidently stated,
bold lies about how the Jews were to blame the Germany's hardships for a
population of people who are desperate.
They clung onto the idea that they could blame the Jews for the economic
problems of Germany.
As time went on,
it became clear to Sefton Delmar and his team that rising Sussel jokes and sexy
stories was not going to be enough to win the war,
so they had to get darker.
Delmas team was able to find the exact typeface used in official German
documents.
This way they created fake court records and leaked to them to the public.
All of these fictional court cases were made to have the SS officers guilty of
rape and murder.
He wrote excruciating details of the story only to have them acquitted of all
charges by the end.
This was obviously meant to outrage.
Anyone who read the documents and it made the Nazi government look like complete
monsters.
He wrote these to try to convince the German people that they were fighting for
an evil and corrupt government.
In 1943 he decided that he wanted it to stop the de chef broadcast,
but he knew that his character would never actually stop his radio broadcast and
less he was forced to,
so he wrote and stage to seed were Nazi soldiers,
came through the door to his studio and shot him.
While he was live on APP.
He hopes that if Nazi soldiers were out there listening,
they would realize that there was no such thing as freedom of the press and a
fascist government.
The longer the war wins on the higher the stakes became.
They felt that it was necessary to mess with the minds of German men in the
darkest white.
A lot of the information that was given to the black propaganda writers came
from highly skilled British intelligence agency were interrogating captured Nazi
soldiers.
Whenever a Nazi soldier refused to say anything about his top secret
information,
they would try to get into relax and talk about his personal life instead
without realizing it.
These soldiers were giving up information about the basis where they were
staying.
The bars were German soldiers,
drag and so on.
So since the names and details given out about the man on the radio or accurate,
they believed there must be a spy among them who was giving away all of their
information.
This made the Germans distrust one another and it was difficult for them to form
a close bond with their comrades.
They would read out the names of streets that had been apparently bombed in
Berlin and Hamburg.
Even if they hadn't,
they purposefully figured out where German you bomb lived so that they could
read out the specific addresses of all the men who were on the boats.
This would make the soldiers fall into a state of depression and anxiety and
completely ruin the morale.
Many of those German soldiers would go through the rest of the war feeling like
there's nothing to fight for.
The British also drops photographs of dead women and children over German basis,
which made them wonder if their own wives and children were among the debt.
Many of these men would be in the shock of their lives to go home and find out
that their family was still very much alive.
The Germans chose to do the same sort of propaganda.
I can leave with a strategy to make the allied soldiers want to end the war and
go home.
They played on men's jealousies with a sultry female voice playing over the
radio asking if they knew what their wives and girlfriends were doing without
them.
By the time the Americans during the war,
German planes were dropping leaflets of fake life magazines featuring
photographs of nude women on one side and death with a skull wearing a helmet on
the other.
There was also one leaflet that says,
gentlemen prefer blondes,
but blondes don't like cripples with the picture of an American veteran and
beauty.
All of these dark campaigns that just have to in Delmas most heartless project,
yet it was called the dead letters.
British intelligence.
We're able to intercept letters written to German soldiers who it actually died.
Many of them were from concerns,
mother saying that they had not heard from their sons in awhile and they hoped
that they were safe.
If British intelligence managed to intercept those letters,
Delmar could write back to these families came that the men were in hiding and
would soon be home.
At first.
This sounds like he was actually being kind to these German families.
Best off to reading enough of these letters over the radio.
The German soldiers who heard the broadcasts would hear the names of the men
they saw dying in front of their eyes.
They knew that someone was lying and they believe that the dead letters were
coming from the German government during these dark times.
Sefton dumb,
his wife,
Isabelle,
could not take it any longer.
She resented Delmar for how cruel he was being to his fellow human beings wall
or not.
The propaganda wasn't funny anymore.
She couldn't handle having any part of us and they ended up getting divorced.
The wall had left it scars and Isabelle would go through two more marriages
before the end of her life.
After World War Two stepped in Delmar,
return to his job at the daily express.
He published a novel called black and boomerang in 1962 but beyond that,
he lived out a quiet retirement.
So we'll just see Chrissy.
He never fully revealed the details of his time creating black propaganda until
the 1970s when enough time had passed and he was able to finally talk about his
experiences in his autobiography,
the counterfeit spy.
Today few people remember Sefton Demo,
how he was a voice of opposition for the gem and people who are used to hearing
the lies of out of Hitler and Joseph Girls.
Why don't we may never know just how many people heard is broadcasts.
We do know that his work was one of the many elements that helped the allies win
the war.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe.
Got brand new videos just like this every day of the week.
If you'd like to check out something else that I do right now there,
why not check out my other channel called day I found out.
I'm going to link to that below as well as on the screen now and as always,
thank you for watching.